first off layout for us the two possible
options that Marissa Meyer has in
offloading the steak without paying
Uncle Sam too much too there are
gazillions of options and they've been
pouring all over the yahoos excellent
chief financial officer Ken Goldman has
been getting the advice of everyone who
wants to tell him I've actually SAT with
him a golden state warriors games where
people will walk up to him and offer
advice and what they should be offering
believe that every account and
investment bank isn't banging on his
door with ideas about what could happen
what we're likely to see is some sort of
a spin off into another entity whether
that involves softbank Japan which has a
stake in alibaba as well in the eye
whose operations or some other publicly
traded entity it's hard to know what
they're going to do there are so many
options on the table but the market is
essentially believing that there's
already going to be a tax penalty if you
believe that steak is worth 40 billion
dollars and appends out to be just about
right the company's enterprise value
that is the value of the company of
minus the cash on hand it's just 35
billion so the market believes that
Yahoo is basically worthless and that
the stake in alibaba is worth less than
the steak itself right there's an
there's an assumption of some sort of
tax a taxable event anyway so we'll see
more about that later too okay so but
what I really want to pay okay so i do
want to pin down too though because
there's two that have been used by other
Titans in the industry right Scott
there's uh there's John Malone who is
famous for avoiding taxes might she go
his way which is he usually takes some
of this money spins it off into a
separate company then he then he borrows
off of those off of those assets and
loans back to the parent company and
therefore he's able to avoid taxes this
way and the only way that John Malone
can that that nobody can understand but
John Malone right and then you've got
the Warren Buffett way which is sort of
this cash rich split that process of
avoiding taxes so should she do either
or should she do something else so I
think it's possible I'm not a tax guy
but I think it's interesting that we get
to talk about how we basically don't
give the government money legally so
it's an instrument right and I think
having grown up the cable business
Malone is was will be a genius at this
kind of
structuring so I have to assume that
there's a half a dozen different ways
that that this can be restructured to me
the more fundamental question i just
happen to believe in the long term value
of companies and unfortunately Wall
Street loves the moment so it's a hey
give us the cash or you know in some way
I think that during yang made a
brilliant investment us and Marissa gets
that benefit and has a cash hoard cash
words are good for companies if they
know what to do with it so if if you're
an apple and you have so much cash is
like what we keep inventing new products
can we really do more right Yahoo can do
more so that's that's the to me that's
the fascination and since I'm a company
builder not a cash distributor that's a
short-term longer turning it to build I
think she has opportunity so she first
she did akwa hires and and and she's
made purchases if it were me and this is
bias because I would actually be I think
at the top of their list which is by
young companies that can benefit there
are two kinds of internet company out
there I you keep well there's there's
lots of them I mean it's not it's not so
and you get your six percent banker fee
the you know to me they can either build
inside that's been tough for them and
it's been tough in terms of teams so
they it's hard to invent but i think
that there's a wealth of young companies
like ours that if the Yahoo fire hose
which they get from mail and news and
other things that they do are applied to
companies they take off so for example
in the Commerce space it's kind of you
need to market whether you like it or
not I mean weird our dream is to create
the social commerce company that doesn't
need to market that someone tells
someone else and it and it goes and we
have some of those qualities so in the
internet you have companies that take
off all by themselves those are the
instagrams where word of mouth happens
but then you do have companies there is
classic marketing you know we are going
to see three or four internet companies
spend money to advertise on the superb
all right yahoo has the ability to go
pick up a dozen dreamy small and if one
or two or three of those head then i
think that's a bit early like a venture
capital
Baneen you know it's yeah I mean I in
act in some ways I but I think they they
have the advantage over every venture
venture capital company in that they
have this huge amount of traffic that
they can point right right either raw
investments will pick up the young ish
companies like ours